des retraites que chacun des engagements
la parole et à monsieur paul salen oui
merci monsieur le président à ma
question à laquelle j'ai aussi mon ami
dino cinieri s'adresse au premier
ministre le 26 janvier 2012 françois
hollande alors candidat à la présidence
de la république avait affirmé lors de
son fameux discours du bourget que la
jeunesse sera la priorité de son
quinquennat lui promettant beaucoup
voire trop de merveilles cinq ans plus
tard bien que françois hollande était
élu président de la république
les jeunes attendent toujours que ces
promesses se réalise ils vont même moins
bien qu'en 2012
malgré les millions d'euros dépensés
pour toute une série de dispositifs aux
résultats insuffisants votre majorité à
préférer amadouer la jeunesse à coup de
primes d'activité des d'à la recherche
du premier emploi au lieu de réformer en
profondeur le marché du travail
votre majorité a anéanti l'apprentissage
qui a un niveau aujourd'hui moins élevé
qu'en 2012 car les patrons sont devenues
frileuses en matière d'embauché en
raison des multiples changements de la
législation fiscale votre majorité
malgré les contrats aidés qui ont
concerné trois cent mille jeunes n'a pas
réussi à faire en sorte que l'ensemble
des jeunes est une formation certifiante
lui permettant de s'insérer dans le
monde du travail plus facilement moins
d'un jeune sur deux il ya eu accès votre
majorité en prenant les stages de 15% de
l'effectif a accentué les difficultés
des jeunes ayant besoin d'un stage pour
valider leur cursus la conclusion de
tous vos efforts de toutes ses promesses
c'est un taux de chômage des jeunes qui
n'a pas baissé depuis 2012 voire même
légèrement augmenté avec un jeune sur
quatre au chômage soit 24 20 % de jeunes
au chômage
monsieur le premier ministre
reconnaissez vous que la politique de ce
quinquennat censé être en faveur de la
jeunesse n'est vraiment pas une réussite
la parole est à madame myriam el khomri
ministre du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
paul salen permettez-moi d'abord de
réagir par rapport à certaines choses
que vous trouvez complètement accessoire
qui relève du pouvoir d'achat des jeunes
parce que la question de la précarité
des jeunes elle se pose et lorsque nous
avons ciblé
justement nos dispositifs en direction
des jeunes des plus précaires non
seulement nous en sommes fiers mais nous
l'assumons la prime d'activité n'est
absolument pas accessoire que cinq cent
mille jeunes et puis en bénéficier que
les jeunes en période d'apprentissage
aujourd'hui puissent bénéficier de ces
périodes d'apprentissage dans le calcul
des droits à la retraite je trouve ça
qu'il est il est particulièrement normal
que nous améliorons les bourses des
jeunes c'est une chose aussi qui permet
de lutter contre la précarité
voilà ce que nous avons fait et puis
monsieur le député permettez moi de vous
dire la garantie jeunes vous n'avez pas
cité ses près de 1700 jeunes dans votre
de votre département qui en ont
bénéficié
concrètement c'est un dispositif
d'accompagnement intensif qui porte qui
a des résultats
alors d'abord première erreur premier
mensonge le show maltais permettez moi
d'y revenir
nous avons des oui mais je suis désolé à
mensonges répétés mille fois ne devient
pas une réalité désolé de le dire ici
nous avons le jeu de jeunes en catégorie
a de pôle emploi a diminué de 25 milles
par rapport à mai 2012
le chômage des jeunes sur l'année 2007 a
diminué de 8,8 pour cent
voilà cette réalité nous avons
intensifié la formation des jeunes le
plan 500000 formation fait d'ailleurs
avec les régions celles qu'on souhaitait
venir avec nous près de 30% des jeunes
en bénéficient
est-ce qu'il faut continuer bien
évidemment le président hollande s'était
engagé à 150 mille jeunes emplois
d'avenir
nous avons doublé cet effort il ya trois
cent mille jeunes comme ont bénéficié
près de 27000 personnes qui ont
bénéficié de contrats aidés dans votre
département
voilà quelle est la réalité il faut que
nous continuions le fait de permettre le
permis de conduire à travers le compte
personnel d'activité permettra également
d'améliorer l'insertion des jeunes et
tous les jours jusqu'à la merci